what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time while
watching trying to get rich wrestlers
just trying to get a lunch money right
do you see the halo around my head it's
i'm like an
angel she probably disagrees but that's
fine i'm here with the beautiful and
intelligent polina e by local marine
should we do like a like a gun show now
like this no
no no all right just just check it just
check it i'm always ready to pull them
out in case i need to don't forget that
lunch money is not sponsored by block
five
go get an interest bearing account you
can earn up to eight point six percent
in their interest bearing account i'm an
investor i sit on the board i love the
product
i put my money in they give me a check
every monday uh
of the month it's awesome or i guess the
first monday of every month not every
monday
uh go check them out dot com
actually let me give you a check they
actually just deposited in your account
but
you know i like saying checks because it
makes it sound fancy uh blockfight.com
go get an account right now go do it go
do it go do it go do it
all right what's up all right have you
done it yeah i i did
no no i'm asking the people did i do
what
no i'm asking the people if they did it
he said but i did it okay
good job did you get a gold star nice
nice because i'm an angel the election
is only 15 days away but no matter who
wins the u.s
presidential contest in november one of
the most pressing
problems for the administration to solve
will be america's broken jobs problem
uh smp global chief us economist beth
ann bovino said
the harsh reality is that whoever the
president is on january 20th has his cut
work cut out for him um you know the
labor market data shows that the economy
uh is mired in a weak recovery with the
unemployment rate still high at 7.9
percent
it ain't 7.9 it's way higher than that
all right
it is chief economist of new york city
please just so we're clear majority of
the people watching this youtube video
right now are smarter than these
economists
trust me there's not 7.9 unemployment in
the united states it's way higher than
that it's the official movement
in april it was 14.7 percent when it
peaked
it wasn't 14.7 it was over 20 percent
literally think about this there's 155
million americans in the global
or in the us workforce and over 55
million of them
filed for first-time unemployment claims
so a third of people filed for
unemployment claims but somehow
unemployment only peaked at 14.7 percent
but someone that may have gotten other
jobs
where'd they get a job when the economy
was shut down
just saying i'm just saying i'm just
saying all right
go ahead all right so who cares who the
president is that's what i continue to
say
like whoever the president will be they
have a big problem to deal with yeah
people don't like when i say this but it
doesn't matter who the president is in
the sense of the checks and balances in
the united states normally
really limit the power that president
has where the president has
impact is in the culture that they set
in terms of the tone and
and the way that they um can get people
excited or
depressed and all that kind of stuff but
uh part of the beauty of the united
states is that
we have a system of checks and balances
we have three separate
parts to the government and it is a
system where
one individual even if they are
president cannot necessarily
make massive massive changes would you
ever run for president
no i like my private life i'm chilling
what if i run for president i'll be your
biggest supporter
all right i just want to be a janitor at
the white house if you'll laugh no you'd
be first man there hasn't been one of
those yet
i've been first man my whole life i
ain't never been second in anything
let's go what's next
oh boy okay so get this the number of
unbanked americans those without a
checking or savings account at a bank or
credit union
has been slowly dropping according to
the fdic
only 5.4 percent of u.s households or
approximately 7.1 million homes were
unbank lacked
last year that's really low and it says
that
it's all the tech startups this is the
lowest rate reported
since the fdic started surveying
americans in 2000 it's all the tech
companies what do you mean
like all these uh neo banks and like i
think i don't know
well okay so cash app i bet you if you
have a cash app account then all of a
sudden accounts we have a checking or
savings account at a bank or a credit
union right
well that maybe cash app specifically
doesn't count because
they do have to have some sort of bank
to
of course you got to be able to use the
products right so like there's all those
types of things then also you can just
go on and i don't remember the names of
all these but like you can literally
just go
make a couple of taps on a app or on a
website that's not what this article
says
what do they say they just say that it's
you know
the improvement of the socio-economic
status of people
i know it just magically got fixed who
are these people
well i i'm not going to say what website
you're reading but that's all i needed
oh wait no no they do say
okay online payment systems like paypal
or fintech companies like chime and
simple
you know it's almost like i read the
internet and i understand technology
trends
actually shockingly they didn't say it
okay what do you mean
all right well there are many options
that than ever for consumers who want to
operate without a bank such as prepaid
credit cards
whatever consumers who have their
employer directly deposit their paycheck
onto a prepaid debit card instead of
into a checking account
typically pay a bunch of fees those who
use cash can face annual costs for check
cashing and money order services
see told you all right next
so we've talked about rent in new york
what about rents in san francisco what
do you think happened there
not great things rents continue to drop
in some of america's most expensive
cities
one of those is san francisco the medium
the median rent for a studio apartment
fell to 2285 a month
down 31 from a year ago my god it was
even higher than that
yeah i lived in a studio in new york
city for like 1750
in 2014. on the upper east side
next to central park all all i want to
say
is my guess is that san francisco rents
aren't just down because the pandemic
are they down because because they got
drug addicts
all over the streets they got freaking
crime going everywhere
and look i don't care actually who the
mayor is or who the local
uh governance is i think it's just a
city problem
where you can't have that happening
and expect people to be excited about
living there
you just have to you just have to clean
up
the cities it can't be trash everywhere
like i've literally right every time i
go to san francisco
i literally just yeah like and i
literally see people taking a poop
on the sidewalk one time i called him
and it was like before 7am
i was going to work it was in san
francisco and i called him i was like
oh i just saw somebody drop their pants
in front of me it's before 7 30. i can't
even get my coffee yet it's not even a
joke it's like like legitimately if you
if you've lived in san francisco for
like six months you've probably seen
somebody poop on the sidewalk
like think about that for a second how
it's just you can't expect people to
want to live somewhere
when that's what's going on all right
let's just move i feel like cities have
cycles
and new york have that kind of cycle in
the age san francisco's off cycle right
now
impossible foods you know the chicken
balls the fake chicken balls
yeah they make um they make meat
that is is it plant-based or is this
plant-based okay so they are for the
first time
they are expanding beyond the us um
the company's flagship imitation beef
product went on sale in 200 supermarkets
across hong kong and singapore on
tuesday
impossibles products are already
available in restaurants in both
regions that's pretty cool that's cool
are they are they public yet
uh i think they are yeah i think
possible foods is i think i'm pretty
sure
because there was beyond meats too that
one yeah i mean look
this is uh this is natural right like in
order to continue to grow you got to get
outside of the u.s
why do you think they chose asia um
i have no clue well i mean if i had to
guess and again i could be completely
wrong but my guess is that they actually
uh it's a very plant-based friendly uh
society
it says that the mainland mainland china
accounts for 28
of global meat consumption the largest
share of any one country
though china's per capita meat
consumption is half the u.s rate
well just so you guys know that just
proved me wrong
but that's interesting i mean all right
what's next
okay we're in a rush today because i got
things i got to do
you don't like being by the way thank
you for subscribing to my youtube
channel
interview coming later today we don't
have time for uh your youtube he's
wearing a profile shirt
um moral support a 102 year old
world war ii maryland veteran
check skydiving off her bucket list
she is 102 years old she went skydiving
on sunday
uh vivian millie bailey she's 20
102 and she got she was inspired by
president
george h.w bush who did it at age 90 and
she said
i was inspired by the fact that he did
it the fact that a person at that age
could do the job
role i love this stuff you want to live
your life go do things you want to do
who cares
you might have like a heart attack then
you're gonna have a heart attack you're
gonna die doing some epic [ __ ]
you wanna die laying in bed at the
hospital you wanna die skydiving
sign me up for the skydiving oh
all god all right guys well you're all
gonna catch me on my motorcycle
flying down the highway at 170.
with your cane nah i don't need no cane
i got my bike
see ya you'll be annoying the hell out
of me
all right what's next final final story
when we were
in bulgaria my great-grandparents they
have been married
they had been married forever um and
one of them would say something the
other one would miss here and the
conversations were just
impossible and i was like that's that's
how it's it's already like that i don't
know
what let's see okay all right let's go
hit me with you
oh that's right why are you waving to
anybody
um this show would suck if it wasn't for
me what's it called when you kill
chickpeas yes no
homicide like hummus because of the
chickpeas
yeah hummus isn't i never mind i don't
want to spread hummus propaganda he had
hummus last night and he loved it
lebanese
i'm not i don't really oh you don't like
coming my hummus is all right like it's
like one of those foods that you kind of
eat but you don't really like it it's
like on a spectrum
there's things that i love like dominoes
and bud light and then there's things
that i absolutely
hate dominoes oh yeah dominoes if
anybody doesn't know this domino's stock
is up 400
in the last five years so
i'm not smart but i am an idiot either
that's fine
i bet you what's budweiser stock look at
budweiser real quick i bet you budweiser
stocks up big
what is budweiser just type in budweiser
i i
got it if you type in budweiser and then
all of a sudden the internet will go
fine
so don't no click click i'm clicking
this yep click that
budweiser which has bud light which is
my favorite it's like water for the
common man
oh it's down guys it's down oh hold on
oh it's still dead oh wow actually in
the last five years budweiser stock is
down big oh
in 10 years it was up big
it was in 2010 yeah 2016 it was up real
big and then it uh kind of fell off
there
it's all right budweiser bud light is
the beer for the common man
thing like pilsners all right this has
gone off the reels all right
goodbye guys
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends